i walked down the street and [ __ ] the
other day this was in santa barbara
santa barbara was insane
and this guy like every now and then
cinema was like a place where a lot of
people were coming up to me i don't know
what it is that's my demo but like
this dude i was walking down the street
and some dude i was just like i'm gonna
go get some [ __ ] i don't know i was
hungry right and i saw this this pasta
place and i was like this is what i want
but then they had zucchini pasta i was
like this is what i want and also i can
keeps it healthy
and so this guy looks at me before i
walk into the pasta place and i can tell
he's going to say something he just goes
like this
right anytime a guy looks at you like a
[ __ ] meer cat and you're a little bit
famous you're like here he comes and
he's just like
and and i i don't look i go straight
because
if you dance with him a little bit it's
sometimes awkward and i understand how
that could make me by the way somebody
came up to me today and they're like i
know you hate when fans come up with you
to come up to you and i and i don't hate
that
but come correct
i don't hate that at all but this is a
transaction let's get it done
in fact i don't hate it i love it
but i'm correct right so i got this
meerkat looking at me from across the
street and i'm like let me just dip into
this pasta place get some zucchini pasta
so i get it
and i see the guy waiting outside of the
[ __ ] zucchini pasta place and i'm
like great
now i gotta have pressure while i eat
but i'm not gonna go back outside
because what if he just wants to stare
i mean i do the thing sometimes where i
jump the gun and i'm like you want a
picture and they're like nah bro and i'm
like
no i
it's so i
i know
so i'm chilling in the pasta place
waiting for my food
and then he comes in and he says hey man
i say what's up and he says dude what
are you doing here
and i'm like i'm just gonna probably eat
some pasta and he was like yeah but like
you have a show out here and i was like
nah actually just chilling because i
don't want to get in i'm saying get
married and then he's like oh really and
we got to talk so long right
grateful for the dude that he knows who
i am but
and he goes like this ah cool man well
like i
i love your stuff man i'm a big fan i
say oh thanks so much dude and he says
you want to do my podcast
and i'm just like
everybody's got [ __ ] okay everyone's
got a [ __ ] podcast then huh
[ __ ] dead people have podcasts now
it's like the podcast of napoleon robin
they they're like we've reincarnated
napoleon and also we've reincarnated a
regular guy there's just so many they're
a duo that has a podcast now
napoleon and frank
hey napoleon how was it invading
everybody giving them [ __ ] leprosy
this podcast makes no sense
hey napoleon don't you like talk regular
[Laughter]
napoleon and frank
they both used to be dead now they have
a podcast
so i'm just like
he says you want to do my podcast and i
[ __ ] literally said
no
but i'll take a picture with you and he
was like oh dude
you know what i don't have a phone
[Laughter]
hey guy
you want a podcast
step one
have a phone
the guy goes like this oh dude i don't
have a phone
then how do you have a podcast
how does santa barbara exist is what i'm
saying it's like [ __ ]
fantastic beasts and where to find them
this is where you find them in santa
barbara
there were some fantastic beasts
it was unbelievable dude crazy
crazy
[Music]
crazy
[Music]